regarder des deux côtés de la route
avant de traverser sur un passage piéton
ne pas jouer au courir sur les trottoirs
circuler en sécurité dans la rue ça
s'apprend dispensés depuis 2006 par la
gendarmerie et la police dans les
classes de ce2 volontaire la formation
au permis piéton concerne désormais
toutes les classes de ce2 soit quinze
mille élèves sensibilisés
on est allé dans deux classes avec les
enseignants il a proposé à un petit but
document avait un petit film et par la
suite les enseignants lui un petit temps
de travail avec des enfants et depuis
début juin
on a fait des évaluations qui a démarré
début jusqu'à la fin juin une
sensibilisation travailler et
approfondies avec leurs professeurs afin
de les préparer à l'examen final on
était très très passionnée vraiment très
intéressé parce que la plupart sont tous
des enfants qui viennent à pied à
l'école non ça allait parler beaucoup
on a fait quelques séances en classe on
a beaucoup discuté on a travaillé dans
un manuel avec beaucoup d'illustrations
et puis on s'est raconté des histoires
des histoires quand vous traversez les
enfants comment vous fret etc
on essayé d'imaginer des actions ce qui
permettait de voilà d'expliquer un peu
mieux les dangers de la route pour les
piétons j'ai appris que c'était bien
d'apprendre ça parce que d'habitude
j'écoute pas ma mère et je vais les
portes ou l'accident
à la clé de cette formation les élèves
de ce2 reçoivent leur tout premier
diplôme
le permis piéton un permis remis pour
les classes des écoles primaires du
centre-ville de saint-denis lors d'une
cérémonie organisée au jardin de l'état
au ce2 c'est le premier permis qui passe
premier permis premières connaissances
en sécurité routière au cm2 sa bête pour
le vélo en cinquième ils vont travailler
pour le cyclomoteur et enfin en
troisième avant de repasser la
nécessaire de cette fois c'est pour
conduire la voiture en la sécurité
routière c'est une éducation au respect
de la règle respect de la règle quel que
soit l'endroit où on est
on a des règles bonjour les enfants le
département fait partie des nombreux
partenaires de cette manifestation une
compétence facultative mais citoyenne
pour assurer la sécurité des jeunes
enfants à travers nos actions que nous
menons envers notre petit public les
petits enfants que son primaire au
collège et bien scellé sensibiliser
c'est leur donner de bons réflexes et
bons outils pour qu'ils soient qu'ils
fassent un vraiment vraiment très très
attention parce qu'il ya encore beaucoup
trop de personnes qui trouvent la mort
malheureusement sur nos routes
en effet 35 enfants piétons âgés de 8 à
9 ans ont été impliqués dans un accident
de la route entre 2010 et 2015
l'intérêt de cette formation est de
donner aux enfants les moyens de pouvoir
circuler en ville en toute sécurité en
respectant les règles et en les
partageant